I like to get it wrong
we have won eight consecutive world
championships in a row and hasn't been
done by any other team in any sport it's
difficult enough to win one and I think
we have been able to set the right
objectives every single year with the
team
I believe that we simply got it wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
Turtle wolf is one of those if you know
you know guys in lots of places heat
pass is a typical successful Global
businessman A well-dressed multilingual
guy on the move but for a growing
segment of the sports obsessed World
he's a guess who I saw without your
phone to prove it celebrity the CEO
co-owner and team principal of the
Mercedes AMG Patronus Formula One Team
Wolf commands a billion dollar
Enterprise one that's implanted itself
into racing fans Consciousness with an
unprecedented run of success a run that
just at least took a pause
we knew that at a certain stage that
winning streak is gonna end
[Music]
but all of us see this as a fantastic
test because with all the business
issues and and problems and challenges
that that need to be faced keeping the
cool Under Pressure uh trying to believe
in the science and trust it's physics
it's not Mystics but giving it the
necessary time and understanding that
you can't accelerate learning into a
certain degree that's fantastic
Formula One it is one of the most
difficult Sports to succeed in literally
everything has to come together man and
machine Within These race weekends and
the margins of success or failure are
incredibly incredibly small we're
talking about thousands of seconds that
could make the difference
I'm not worried about anything in my
professional life things happen for a
reason my perspective is beyond 10 years
it's not just a single race
the the weekends or the races we lose
are the ones that our competitors will
regret the most because we learn the
most it's going to make us better
in racing if you're not winning you're
losing it's just that simple and after
one of the most trying years in the
team's history wolf is hell-bent on
showing he still knows how to win
[Music]
Monaco occupies a quirky spot in the
collective Global imagination Yachts
casinos and of course fast cars it's
tiny the second smallest country in the
world so small that when you're driving
in from the airport in nearby knees if
you miss the exit you could end up in
Italy theoretically
like the signage has changed
once you're there it has a fairy tale
quality right down to the Palace that
sits on the hill overlooking the harbor
There's an actual Prince living there
with his family and Prince Albert's
family has long been beyond supportive
of the sport that put Monaco on the map
but I'm here to meet up with someone
many consider modern F1 royalty thank
you
[Music]
I got you
copy me
[Music]
what they used to do in the past
is that they just drove with doors open
but you need to be careful that you're
not
crashing anybody out today
[Music]
that is much more pleasant on a hot day
in Monaco
[Music]
I mean obviously this car attracts
attention but
you now attract attention actually
it's an interesting life experiment for
me because I'm not a sport person but
grew up with that I think let's close it
for the time being
[Music]
public I saw my heart me much later in
my life where I think my character was
already done and couldn't influence me
in a negative way it shows that the
popularity of the sport
and of um and of the team and public
recognition will be always something
that is flattering and you must take it
for granted
tell me about Monaco I mean this is the
Cradle in many ways
of this sport
how do you view it Formula One is Monaco
Monaco's Formula One
if you ask someone that has heard about
Formula One and knows a little bit about
it they will associate Formula One with
Monaco
it's by far the most popular race
now obviously Miami was great and Las
Vegas coming in hopefully they're gonna
go They're gonna be bigger as well but
Monaco was always a glamorous town that
was known for Formula One
wolf who grew up in Austria picked up
racing at 17. but by 1994 his
performance on the track sent him
searching for another challenge he
looked to business
as a young man you got me a racing
driver you'd like to be an investment
banker that at least was uh how how it
happened to me in the late 1990s the
internet came out and with it the boom
of startup businesses with valuations
going astronomical a little bit to what
we have experienced until most recently
and I I jumped on that bandwagon
through investing firms March 15 and
March 16 he enjoyed the success of
the.com era and also the less sexy world
of investing in industrial companies his
success in the investment World allowed
him to get back into the business of
racing
and then came the call do you want to
become a partner in numbers
myself I'm very excited obviously to be
representing Mercedes-Benz in Formula
One in 2013 Toto would take over
management of the Mercedes F1 team but
his investments in the team also meant
that he would own about a third of the
overall franchise
a good investment considering under his
leadership the Mercedes team would go on
an unprecedented run Lewis Hamilton
would win seven straight drivers
championships and Mercedes would win
eight Constructors titles that's the
team prize it takes into account Point
totals from each team's two drivers it
was a level of domination rarely seen in
F1 or any sport for that matter
toad also turned the sport into a true
family business marrying his wife Susie
herself a former British Pro Driver
she most recently ran a team on the
Formula E circuit that's the electric
car division of the fia the governing
body that also includes formula one I
got to catch up with a couple just over
the Border in France with a view you
might only get dining with the ultimate
Motorsport power couple
so what is it like for the two of you to
work in the same business well I can't
speak for today but I I certainly I love
what he does I'm I'm very very proud but
I also love following it from the
sidelines of watching the races coming
to some races but
I also love I mean from him I learned so
much over the years which is part of the
reason why I felt that I could take on
the role and form the EU
Susie started racing even earlier than
Toto when she was about eight years old
decided to become a racing driver at the
age of 13. Susie and Toad his past
crossed when she was with Mercedes-Benz
and German touring cars
I went to a race in New York and I
remember
standing being able to see the Statue of
Liberty with these electric racing cars
and obviously the diesel gate happened
and everything
sped up in the automotive industry and
then I thought this is this has got
something and I literally just
copy and pasted told him to deal with
Mercedes and said okay I don't I don't
need a salary but I want equity
I remember there was one instance at the
beginning and formerly we were
struggling and I had both cars in the
top and one after the other the old
stopped with the same problem on the
drive shaft and I was getting phone
calls people obviously very dis very
unhappy that we had this issue and then
I called totally said what happened I
said we have this issue with the drive
shafts and he said sorted
I said yeah I better try something I'm
not the technical director I don't even
know what the issue is he's like it's
your problem
you have to sort it but it was awesome
that moment that I realized that the
buck stops with you it's about very
quickly fixing issues and and finding
Solutions
during his tenure with Mercedes wolf has
become a master at solving problems and
managing Talent including Hamilton
indisputably the most famous driver on
the circuit over the past decade
Wolf's role as both owner and manager of
a record-setting sports franchise is
unique imagine if the Patriots Robert
Kraft and Bill Belichick were the same
person which is how Toto ended up
teaching a case about himself at Harvard
Business School
someone like a total wolf any team
principle really is is responsible for
hundreds of people right Mercedes has
1800 people across the the factory and
the unit where they actually look after
the engines so 1800 people who he has to
manage and what struck me is the
remarkable attention to detail that he
brings to the table the governing body
the FIA is set up to not have anyone win
uh eight times in a row this is all
about trying to maintain a competitive
balance so against all those odds in an
incredibly difficult environment the
Mercedes team was able to keep a winning
streak alive for eight years that I
thought was a was a really interesting
premise for a case study Anita Alberti
is a Harvard Business School Professor
specializing in the intersection of
entertainment media and sports
she's written case studies on figures
like LeBron James Maria Sharapova The
Rock and Beyonce putting people at the
center analyzing mistakes very
rigorously having an open atmosphere in
which everyone can speak up if they see
something that needs to be fixed and
then also actually having the
willingness to try to fix what has been
going wrong this Relentless pursuit of
winning and never giving into
complacency
[Music]
the last 10 years have been a critical
growth period for Formula One racing
spurred by the 4.4 billion purchase of
F1 by John Malone's Liberty Media in
2017.
Toto saw firsthand how much the ambition
for the sport accelerated with Liberty
coming in although we were skeptical at
the beginning that's where we really
started to have this massive upswing and
together with the governing body dfae we
were able to put on a show during covet
as the only Global spot and it obviously
helped a lot
the business of Formula One it's a bit
more complicated than it might seem from
just watching a race there's a global
governing body for the 10 teams Each of
which is an independently run business
like pro basketball or football teams
each has its ownership group those teams
get cuts of overall formula and revenue
based on each season's performance
those teams also have sponsors who pay
for the right to have their names on the
cars helmets or other team materials
like crew shirts finally there are
promoters they buy the right from F1 to
host races in individual locations
usually for several years at a time they
recoup their money and earn profits from
selling hospitality and other
sponsorships
since buying F1 in 2017 Liberty has
grown revenue for The Circuit by 20
despite a global pandemic Revenue
totaled 2.1 billion dollars in 2021.
being a sharehold and a company and
managing it it is always about
profitable growth nevertheless the
biggest part of the return on investment
was the advertising value that we
generated for Mercedes and our partners
lap time and performance always
outweighted profitability
perhaps the biggest change came with a
radically disrupted media landscape so
it's helpful to have one of the world's
most influential media and
Communications companies as your owner
what are you doing
understanding goodbyes and he is through
via later social media staunchly
resisted by the previous management
became a new vehicle for promotion and
to connect teams and drivers to their
fans augmenting even supplanting the one
stodgy single broadcast for each race
now instead of engaging a couple dozen
Sundays a year fans had deep and direct
ongoing access and then there was that
show
all I do is pray for a safe race
you need to respect to speed but the
second the driver has fears you need to
retire the Mercedes team wasn't included
in the first season of drive to survive
that was Toto's decision
one of the reasons I didn't want to do
it because I didn't want our engineers
and drivers to act like in a movie yeah
right rather than being fully
concentrated on the job while capturing
failures on camera might not have been
ideal for Toto and his team for the
sport of F1 it's been a massive success
after seeing what one season did for the
sport and his Rivals he signed up for
season two and an entirely new level of
Fame and notoriety for his team and for
him followed it launched a boom and it
opened up a completely new audience
different to the hardcore fans
especially in the United States with
Austin and Miami already on the calendar
in 2023 F1 will return after four
decades to Las Vegas for a nighttime
race that will include the famous Vegas
strip It's Quickly becoming one of the
hottest tickets in sports with the three
us races and five in North America
including Montreal and Mexico City the
sport is building a massive us audience
which is always part of Liberty media's
business case
the races on U.S soil are proving wildly
popular in terms of attendance drawing
some of the biggest crowds across the
circuit Miami in its first year
attracted 330 000 fans across the
weekend Austin was the single biggest
event of the year with 440 000
spectators
we arrived in
Miami and there was
lots of of young screaming women and I
thought wow that's new
because before young women would kind of
come up to music oh I love your racing
and but now they come up like oh I love
Toto I love your husband I'm like yeah
so do I
this is the season like nuwado
unbelievable start from Hamilton it's
just insane
the growing audience was used to the
weak-tweek drama of the paddock and the
pits but nothing could prepare fans or
teams for the 2021 season it culminated
in Beyond dramatic fashion with the
driver Championship decided in the final
race in Abu Dhabi on a judgment call by
the official
what happened in Abu Dhabi at the last
race it really captivated people even if
you weren't into Motorsport I mean the
the battle how ferocious it got
between him and the race leader it's
these magnificent Brands it's these
Gladiators on track
giving it everything
[Music]
it's just everything is happening in
that panic
oh the politics this is a mess the
interaction among the stakeholders that
is so not right that is so not right you
think you have the championship then
it's lost another certain stage in jail
the three races before the end I smashed
my headphones because I thought in that
minute Lewis was break tested and we
lost the championship
and then you realize 10 seconds later
it's actually on
he just needs to win the race
we're letting Netflix in and they are
seeing things that otherwise if you look
at the pure sports broadcasting you
wouldn't realize that that by itself
Formula One is drama and have always
been on track and off track there's too
much at stake and now that's being
captured by the lenses
Toto says he hasn't watched more than a
couple episodes of the show and has not
watched the final episode of last season
I certainly didn't want to be reminded
but I felt we needed to watch it once
and I watched of course the last episode
and told us they're doing a short Show's
like you know what don't I I've done it
both of us
it's done and dusted the new season not
only brought little relief but more
challenges new regulations required a
new car design and Mercedes simply got
it wrong in a way that no in-season
tinkering could fix
a cost cap was introduced in the 2021
season and the jury's still out on how
much parity it will bring to the Circuit
it did mean Mercedes couldn't simply
throw money at its design mistake
in the end Mercedes failed to win a
ninth straight team title and neither of
its drivers was ever in real contention
for the driver's Championship to make it
worse for Toto and his team archrival
Red Bull added a constructor's title to
Max verstappen's second straight drivers
championship
the winning stream
guards been a really tough year for
everyone at Mercedes what goes to the
very heart of why they are so successful
is this idea of realizing that losing is
always just around the corner that the
winning at some point will have to end
they were so rigorous in their approach
they always analyze everything win or
lose they were never complacent and I
think that sets them up really well for
future success
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so on race day this office is live onto
the racetrack terra's main office is at
Team headquarters in northamptonshire a
couple hours outside of London this is
where the majority of the team employees
work and only a very small portion ever
seek cars on the track in person on a
regular basis
when I'm sitting on my station and at
the racetrack all the engineers we talk
to the various channels and it can well
be that the engineers are sitting very
much here I wouldn't know the difference
right right and whatever time zone we
are you can see that this 30 Engineers
that are sitting here working live on
strategy giving us live information
about the state of the car and all what
we see on the track is right in front of
us for them to see
so my channels are basically open to I
would say probably 50 Engineers that I
could have a direct discussion with if I
wanted but also fast we have a strict
intercom protocol that we follow and you
can say it's almost like in an airplane
[Applause]
our ambition is to win every single one
but in our sport it's about physics and
not Mystics we got it wrong with the
physics this year
and it is about how can we recover I see
that as a real opportunity for us
because all of these people have been
here when they saw how good it was going
and now how difficult it can be and
that's going to be an important learning
from them also in the future you will
not take it for granted that winning a
championship is easy so I believe
there's always something good in getting
it wrong
even though it feels difficult when it
happens
foreign
not a bad way to spend a two set
the Circuit of the Americas as the
Austin racetrack is known as empty on
this scorching summer day say for a few
dozen Mercedes personnel and some very
excited Mercedes sponsors from
crowdstrike Toto along with Hamilton are
hosting top crowdstrike Executives for
what feels like the ultimate sponsor
perk driving around an F1 track where
the world's most famous driver and is
also very famous boss it's more evidence
of the big money and big audience
opportunity for Mercedes and F1 in
America
U.S continues to fall in love with the
spectacle and drama
in the past it would have been a stick
on the car and I give you visibility and
formula one was very successful at that
because we are the only true big Global
Sport and what has happened over the
last few years that our audiences in the
US literally went through the sky
we generate about a billion and a half
audience every year but it's involved to
much more of an integrated partnership
and it's not a sponsorship anymore in
that sense we have companies that are
working together we try to increase
sales we utilize our Network to really
help the business itself
but our largest countries are about 100
million live audience some of them and
Austin is a good example more than 400
000 people across the weekend and the
marketing side the visibility basically
is the icing on the cake and just comes
on top wow I think we have been able to
really shape and identify our core
values
I feel we're in a good place and having
three races in the US One in Mexico and
one in Brazil it gives us a good
footprint in the Americas Beyond Europe
Australia Asia and it justifies it as a
global sport
this is a good setting okay you can
really go Full Throttle it'll get a
little bit of rotation but it won't spin
out perfect
with every lap every overseas trip and a
season that's only expanding next year
there will be 24 races around the world
Toto moves ever closer to a Crossroads
he signed a three-year contract
extension at the end of 2020. moving out
of day to day after that and remaining
an owner likely a vocal and interested
one feels like a real possibility for
now his sole Focus as F1 gets more
Global and more profitable is getting
Mercedes back on top
that was a racing driver turned Finance
person came back as a team owner and
team manager and I'm also the trainer
I love the sport and this is what I
enjoy doing at the moment but I feel
when it's the fifth time in a row and
you're finishing second or third rather
than winning these things these negative
emotions still kick in at the end the
giant Target The Joint objective is so
massive that we just need to remind
ourselves in these moments that we just
want the same we're just seeing the
solution somewhere so we just need to
get together and say what is it that we
want to do
data important to develop a quick car
but they don't make decisions humans do
[Music]
[Music]